[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique pour un
débat sur l'immigration je commence en
citant les propos du président de la
république
emmanuel macron a déclaré à la mi
septembre en prétendant être humaniste
sonné parfois trop laxistes et puis il a
poursuivi
nous n'avons pas le droit de ne pas
regarder ce sujet en face l'immigration
on en débat avec nos quatre invités tout
d'abord yanbu cas et les députés les
républicains du territoire de belfort
face à lui bruno kern toujours dans le
territoire de belfort mais lui il est
référent pour la république en marche et
licques sylvestre est le délégué
départemental du rassemblement national
pour le jura et puis anthony poulin
d'europe écologie les verts et les
conseiller municipal à besançon
n'oubliez pas si vous voulez commenter
réagir à cette émission
grâce à twitter vous pouvez le faire
hashtag dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté quelques
chiffres pour poser tout d'abord le
débat l'immigration en bourgogne franche
comté c'est simple en 2018 6759
personnes ont obtenu un titre de séjour
c'est un chiffre qui provient de l'ofpra
l'office français de protection des
réfugiés et apatrides qui dépend du
ministère de l'intérieur
et puis j'ajoute que les pays d'où
viennent les immigrés sont l'afghanistan
l'albanie la georgie et la guinée pour
les plus importants d'entre eux entre
ont tout de suite dans le vif du sujet
en parlant des quotas voici ce qu'a
déclaré edouard philippe le premier
ministre lundi devant l'assemblée
nationale
je n'ai pas peur de réfléchir à l'idée
de quotas alors on va faire tout d'abord
un tour de table pour ou contre les
quotas et on va commencer par vous eric
sylvestre du rassemblement national
vous devez être très content de votre
parti puisqu'on parle enfin
d'immigration et on dit que les quotas
pourquoi pas pour notre part emmanuel
macron c'est assumer
comme un immigré parlons comme un
immigrationniste convaincu pendant des
années ils dépensent pour nous tous les
records en la matière et répondez à la
question quotas oui ou non si quotas non
quotas vous voulez aucun immigré
voilà donc vous êtes vous là c'est le
quota zéro en fait on sait tous que
c'est que vous êtes pour un quota c'est
à dire sans aucun aucun immigré parce
que marine le pen parle de submersion
migratoire vous aller jusque là devant
vous proposes tu as toujours été votre
j'allais dire cheval de bataille ça
reste au delà de notre cheval de
bataille une réalité alors il ya une
bluecar vous pour les républicains c'est
oui ou non aux quotas des côtes ans
arrêtée in a déjà dans les préfectures
avec l'accord dit streit séjour etc
à la question c'est de savoir est-ce
qu'on va débattre et voter demain des
quotas au parlement mais la question
n'est pas là la question c'est comment
on fait appliquer la loi
comment faire respecter les décisions de
justice de notre pays comment on
reconduit efficacement aux frontières
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas eu le droit
ni à l'asie le nid ou séjour dans le
pays parce que je reviens à 90% de ceux
qui sont déboutés qui reste sur le
terrain international donc la question
n'est pas de savoir si on meurt jade
j'ai un chiffre il ya entre 80000 et
100000 obligation de quitter le
territoire français oqtf
il y en a que 12 à 15 % qui sont
appliquées donc vous vous dites vous
avant de mettre des quotas
il faut déjà que la loi bruno cannes
pour ou contre les quotas pour vous il
ya deux types de quotas les quotas par
nationalité les quotas par profession
s'il doit y avoir des quotas c'est
plutôt par prospection dans la mesure où
la france doit être en mesure
d'accueillir des professions qui manque
en france et des personnes qui veulent
prendre des vous pensez qu'il ya des
professions en france où on a besoin de
main d'oeuvre d'origine étrangère bah
écoutez allez vous faire soigner à
l'hôpital nord franche comté vous verrez
le nombre de médecins d'origine
étrangère qui sont là parce qu'il n'ya
pas assez de médecins pour vous il faut
accueillir utile jeudi que la france a
des besoins et en termes économiques et
en terme d'emploi et qui à certains
emplois parfois des emplois très
subalternes qui ne sont pas remplies il
ya une inadéquation entre le nom de
chauffe peu de chômeurs et le nombre
d'emplois proposés
les émigrés qui veulent avoir une vie
meilleure et avoir en même temps un
emploi pour sortir de la misère dans
laquelle ils ont pu être sonné bienvenue
dans le cadre de quotas
anthony poulin est chez europe ecologie
les verts vous dites quoi par rapport
aux quotas les écologistes ont toujours
été clair sur cette question nous ne
pensons pas qu'une politique de quotas
est une politique acceptable
on entend tout à l'heure tout de suite
et dans les propos des des autres
intervenants
une histoire qui tournerait autour de la
calculette quelque part on calcule
combien de deux migrants moi je pense
qu'il faut raisonner avec le coeur et la
raison le coeur et dit qu'il faut
accueillir
elle a raison il dit qu'il faut
accueillir dignement et voilà l'enjeu
accueillir dignement la position des
écologistes
il est dans l'accueil digne de tous pour
permettre à tous de vivre bien y compris
les populations de migrants dans l'eau
dans nos villes et sur nos territoires
alors autre question dont il a été donc
question si j'ose dire à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
c'est le regroupement familial faut-il
le supprimer ou pas pour quel motif déjà
les étrangers viennent chez nous alors
en bourgogne franche comté voici les
motifs du titre de séjour
c'est tout d'abord des motifs familiaux
pour 35% dans lequel se situe le
regroupement familial mais il n'ya pas
que ça comme raison les études 28% des
raisons humanitaires 23%
c'est là où il y a le droit d'asile
économique u % divers 5% regroupement
familial yanbu car pour ou contre
on peut pas supprimer totalement
groupement familial serait mentir de
dire l'inversé mais est quelque chose de
très intéressant que vous avez dit c'est
que le regroupement familial une partie
infime du motif d'accueil pour raisons
familiales en 2017 c'est 3000 12000
regroupement familial sur 90 mille
personnes qui sont venues au titré de la
famille donc ça regroupe ça regroupe
plein de choses mais c'est infiniment
d'après vous c'est un faux débat il faut
la voir au 6 mai 2000 personnes ce n'est
pas sur une submersion migratoire mais
il faut qu'on se pose la vraie question
aussi de qui on accueille pour qu'on
accueille dans quel cadre on accueille
au titre de la famille le sud le
regroupement familial
le regroupement familial
je vais dire oui mais pas dans le sens
où on applique pourquoi ne pas regrouper
les familles dans leur pays d'origine
tout simplement à vous êtes pour le
regroupement familial mais dans le pays
d'origine pays d'origine raccompagné les
gens chez eux et regroupé familialement
jeu reprend les propos de monsieur en
face c'est bruno cannes dans le
dessus ou à un moment il parlait
d'accueillir des gens avec des
professions bien spécifique ou autre on
pourrait très bien regroupée un médecin
étranger dans son pays d'origine où je
pense qu'il ya plus besoin de lui dans
son pays d'origine que chez nous et s'il
ya des enfants qui sont nés en france et
qui sont français on en fait quoi on
sépare les familles pas forcément il ya
des sujets plus délicats voilà alors le
regroupement familial anthony poulin
pour europe ecologie les verts pour les
écologistes les choses sont là aussi
claire on défend l'idée que tout le
monde a le droit à une vie de famille et
un respect de sa vie privée dans le
respect des textes fondamentaux et les
conventions internationales qui ont été
signés par la france
et en l'espèce d'ores et déjà en france
nous ne faisons pas respecté l'ensemble
de nos engagements vis-à-vis des alors
une est trop laxiste en fait par le
rehaut droit c'est à dire qu'on devrait
être encore plus accueillant on devrait
être plus accueillant nous devrions
permettre à toutes des personnes
migrantes qui arrivent sur notre
territoire d'être accueillis dignement
parce que nous pouvons le faire en
france nous accueillons 400 mille
migrants
cette année l'allemagne dans dans le
même temps en accueille un million six
nous sommes le 15e pays en europe à
accueillir des migrants le dublin amène
à ce que l'on nous concentrions les
migrants dans les pays de la
méditerranée en italie ou en grèce nous
voyons bien que nous ne sommes pas à la
hauteur des enjeux et que les droits
fondamentaux doivent être absolument
respecter c'est notre position donc la
question c'était regroupement familial
vous dites-vous n'aime pas question on
accueille tout le monde bruno kern
regroupement familial faut le maintenir
de toute façon on peut pas le supprimer
puisque c'est une une obligation niveau
européen et que si la france porté
atteinte au groupe en a pas familiale
elle irait contre les directives
européennes
mais dans ce que j'entends excusez moi
j'ai pas mal d'interrogations
moi je veux bien être le plus le
généreux qui soit alors on accueille
tout le monde pour venir travailler on
accueille tout le monde parce qu'ils
sont en situation difficile politique
une fois on accueille et bien
précisément c'est ce qu'a dit le
président la république
si on veut à qui accueillirent
dignement correctement et leur
permettent d'avoir une vraie vie en
france mais il faut comme il faut
excuser moi il faut avoir un quota
d'émigrés que nous puissions accueillir
avec toutes les administrations à
l'heure vous disions musique bretonne
est un jeu wii parce que précisé vous
précisément vous avez de vous avez
mélangés dans vos propos parce que vous
avez vous dû faire jouer le coeur vous
avez mélangés dans votre peau deux types
d'immigrés il ya ceux qui viennent pour
des raisons économiques parce qu'ils
trouvent pas de travail dans leur pays
et à ceux qui viennent parce qu'ils
fuient la difficulté qu'il ya dans leur
payer cela on doit les accueillir
quand vous dites difficulté c'est par
exemple des délits en guerre les deux
pays en guerre
tout à l'heure on a entendu que on avait
cette année beaucoup d'albanais qui
viennent l'albanie n'est pas un pays en
guerre l'albanie n'est pas un pays
considéré comme un secure et pourtant
nous avons beaucoup de migrer gens qui
viennent sont des gens qui viennent pour
nous et on s'assure économies ont fait
offerts répondent anthony poule à qui on
aimerait vous entendre dire ici à tous
les travailleurs français que vous
voulez accueillir tout le monde y
compris pour qu'il vienne travailler en
france tout le monde
obtenir votre réponse on voit bien que
tout à l'heure vous nous expliquer qu'il
fallait accueillir des personnes
migrantes dans le cadre du travail et
vous et tout suit va vous nous et là on
a des manques et vous doutez vous
expliquer la ou en adhérant je n'en dis
cela je les ai parlé je ne laissez pas
aller si l'ue simplement que nous
pouvons en france accueillir dignement
tout le monde
l'immigration en france rapporte 4
milliards d'euros au pib et ne coûte que
0 5% du pea vous sortez vous ces
chiffres c'est ce sont des chiffres qui
sont qui ont été communiqués notamment
dans le cadre du débat du débat
parlementaire par le gouvernement par
différentes par différentes à des ong
par baddou qui va lui ouvrir plus
largement différente qui travaillent au
quotidien parce que leur est sûr c'est
que ces ong que vous défendez votre amie
anne hidalgo à paris c'est d'avoir le
présentiel et sellerie sa porte à la
saison et jean moussu eu plein de gens
les accueille chez monsieur lumens la
section saisonniers monsieur ce sont des
femmes et des hommes qui sont nos
territoires dans le doubs dans le jura
dans le territoire du golfe
accueille tous les jours des personnes
âgées en situation de vulnérabilité pour
leur permettre d'être accueillis
dignement et je dois vous le dire que
toutes les collectivités que nous sommes
il y en a très peu qui sont à la hauteur
de ces enjeux là il y a un exemple celui
de damien carême il y à d'autres
exemples pour permettre de faire dans
nos villes un accueil digne
un accueil qui répondent aux standards
de l'onu on a compris votre position
anthony poulin a donc après donc les
quotas le regroupement familial
j'aimerais bien que l'on parle de l'aide
médicale d'état qui a suscité beaucoup
de questions cette semaine alors c'est
environ 320 malades 320 mille malades
étrangers qui ont bénéficié après avoir
été accueillis sur le sol français
pendant au moins trois mois
ça coûte 935 millions d'euros soit 0,5
pour cent des dépenses de santé
alors est ce que yann bout car vous
dites comme christian jacob
et comme marine le pen que les aides
sociales et des aides médicales ce sont
des pompes aspirantes de l'immigration
ce que je dis sur l'aide médicale d'état
puisque c'est le sujet que vous évoquez
sait qu'on a une explosion de la
médicale d'état depuis sa création en
2000 en atteindra prochainement le
milliard d'euros de dépenses on a plus
de 300000 personnes qui l'utilisent et
évidemment que la france ne peut pas
laisser sur son territoire des gens à
mourir parce qu'elles n'ont pas les
moyens de se soigner
mais évidemment aussi qu'on doit
regarder comme tous nos partenaires
européens que monsieur qui incitait le
panier de soins qui est compris dans
cette médicale d'état et c'est pour ça
que nous proposer une aide médicale
d'urgence pour effectivement soigner les
urgences et 5% seulement dignement la
principale dépense aujourd'hui c'est la
tuberculose il faut continuer évidemment
à soigner la tuberculose
par contre il faut c'est une mesure de
santé publique en france
santé publique en france pour la
population française et aussi de
solidarité très calmes ans pour pas
laisser des gens à mourir de maladies
mais il faut aussi se poser la question
est ce qu'on continue à rembourser
certaines dépenses dentaire et à quelle
hauteur
quand on voit que certains de nos
concitoyens ont du mal aujourd'hui à se
procurer ses soins c'est des vrais
questions que se pose la beauté
spectateurs qui travaillent et n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de se soigner alors
on essaie sylvestre pour le
rassemblement national l'aide médicale
et l'aide médicale d'état
pour notre part il faut effectivement il
mettre un terme au jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est près de 5 % d'augmentation
tous les ans sur les montants de l'aide
médicale d'état à un moment sauf erreur
de ma part on est à 3500 euros par
bénéficiaire sur cette aide médicale
d'état ce qui représente une somme
conséquente en soins malgré tout 3500
euros n'est pas ce que dit yann bout car
c'est par exemple pour soigner
tuberculose et si on soigne pas la
tuberculose des étrangers qui arrivent
en france s'étaient vidées me peut
s'installer en france alors qu'on a
réussi à d'éradiquer oui certes mais à
ce moment là est ce qu'on doit
accueillir tous les gens qui ont la
tuberculose chez nous tous et à la
frontière il faudrait leur demander si
zola
on avait des frontières établies yachts
et si ce n'était que la tuberculose il
faut il faut un moment qu'on cesse là la
france les finances françaises ne
pourront plus supporter à un moment ses
soins sur des gens qui viennent comme ça
donc vous la réponse à tous et on bloque
les frontaux rétabli les fonds réa blé
les frontières ce qui nous brûle au khan
est médicale d'état c'est là l'intérêt
d'un débat national devant le parlement
parce que ça permet à tout le monde de
s'exprimer et ce qu'a dit le député
républicain il ya deux bouts car je le
rejoins douce nous pensons également
vous est d'accord avec lui je pense
également et nous pensons également que
il faut substituer à l'aide médicale
d'état une aide médicale d'urgence et
faire la différence entre les soins qui
sont indispensables pour bien accueillir
les gens pour leur éviter de tomber dans
des maladies difficiles et même
mortelles et cottages et même des jets
nos concitoyens on peut pas avoir le mât
sur elle à la main sur le coeur en
permanence à ce que pour finir c'est pas
ce qu'on veut aider qui ceux qui sont
aidées c'est tout ce qui les accueillent
qui sont touchés donc à un moment ou un
autre il faut avoir une attitude
responsable et je me réjouis qu'au
parlement l'y aider des convergences qui
se fasse sur i on a vu que le débat
était plutôt apaisée entre la république
marché la république à moi je suis ravi
qu'on ait la même fin le même avis sur
la question
ce qui est juste de machette dans le
cadre de lois asile immigration ce que
je viens d'expliquer ce sur quoi vous
êtes d'accord on l'a proposé le groupe
l'est républicain avec christian jacques
aubé avec eric ciotti je regrette juste
que le gouvernement et la majorité ne
l'est pas
elle est pas mis dans la loi parce que
du coup on est d'accord les deux ça
serait aujourd'hui appliqué il fallait
faire sous sarkozy aurait été interrogé
qu'une chose la loi je précise juste une
chose de lalo asile et immigration ce
qu'on appelle aussi la loi colons elle
est là un peu plus d'un an et s était
sauf erreur de ma part pour donc c'est
durcir l'accueil renforcer l'intégration
et c'était la 17e loi sur l'immigration
depuis 1981 anthony poule à l'aide
médicale d'état vous allez dire vous
êtes d'accord
il faudrait tout l'alcool moi je n'ai
entendu aussi la ministre de la santé un
dire qu'il ne fallait pas supprimer
l'aide médicale d'état
donc oui il y à des enjeux sanitaires
extrêmement important il a des envies de
santé pour ces populations qui pour la
plupart ont quand même traversé des pays
les continents les maires et qui
arrivent dans des situations difficiles
et il faut pouvoir être à là à la
hauteur de cet accueil vous avez dit ce
chiffre peut-être début 0,5 pour cent
des dépenses descente et de santé parce
que des pensions c'est marginal
je note je note quelque chose d'autre un
rapprochement idéologique qui fait que
macron aujourd'hui fait du sarkozy effet
de du migron quelque part le bouc
émissaire qu'il faut sortir parce que
c'est vrai vous avez raison les uns les
autres
il ya une vraie précarité sociale une
vraie inégalité face aux enjeux du
changement climatique mais au lieu
d'apporter des solutions sur ces
questions là on ressort la figure du
migrant pour cristalliser des débats
alors que ce n'est pas la préoccupation
des français
la même série a donné les pays d'arrivée
tout à l'heure est-ce que les albanais
ce que les géorgiens fui la précarité
climatique moi je veux bien qu'on parle
des îles qui sont envoyées par le par la
montée de la mer etc
on est d'accord c'est la question que
bien mais est-ce que la moitié de la mer
juste un chiffre la banque mondiale
affirme que d'ici 2050 pour la zone
subsaharienne
il y aurait je dis bien au rythme aurait
86 millions de réfugiés climatiques vous
avez raison de rappeler ce chiffre se ce
chiffre là c'est en jeu des réfugiés
climatiques
il n'est pas présent dans le document
qui a été remis aux députés
ce n'est pas un ange est aujourd'hui
considéré par le gouvernement alors que
c'est mentir à tout le monde que de dire
que
migration vont se stopper toujours est
il que les réfugiés climatiques c'est
pour dans plus tard c'est là aujourd'hui
par exemple d'y avoir fugier aventures
d'un homme qui arrive en france
monsieur sylvestre pour le rassemblement
national les kurdes vous en faites quoi
les cures c'est un sujet extrêmement
compliquée avec la turquie qui joue un
double jeu depuis deux ans va faire un
an que je dis aux politiques mais là il
ya des déjà des dizaines de milliers de
kurdes qui quittent les zones d'eau qui
sont bombardés par la turquie on les
refuse oui on les refuse on les refuse
oui c'est sûr vous pouvez pas ne pas
entendre ça
mais si on les refuse une horde
aujourd'hui on ne peut malheureusement
on ne peut plus accueillir on ne peut
plus accueillir les gens de tous les
pays disons aux flics vous estimez vous
êtes simian et vous vous estimez
français l'histoire de la france elle
est faite aussi de cette histoire
d'accueil ou histoire de la france a le
fait d'aider des migrations qui traverse
les uns et les autres des migrations et
de gens qui se sont intégrés chez nous
est de l'accueil on peut pas un moment
donné dans notamment dans votre dans
votre parti politique faire le mettre en
avant un certain nombre de deux figures
lors de l'or dès lors des différents
conflits qui ont des justes ou autres
qui ont fait un certain nombre de choses
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui s'appuyer sur
ce genre de choses et dire que les
personnes aujourd'hui qui font la même
chose en france qui font de cette
solidarité serait condamnée par à faire
répondre monsieur sylvestre on a compris
et l'idée que vous avanciez donc les
kurdes
pour l'instant on ne peut plus
accueillir non plus et ces gens parmi
les kurdes qui vont arriver on aura on
aura toute une frange de gens dont on ne
dompte on ne connaîtra pas les l'origine
parmi ces kurdes y aura sûrement des
djihadistes ils se seront mélangés à la
population
on voit ce que john
les djihadistes en france il ya une
semaine les gens voulaient d'un beck
hansen love s'était pas dire seulement
tous
il ya une semaine c'était quelqu'un qui
était né dans les dom-tom s'était pas
quelqu'un qui était né à l'étranger
il était français r je suis levé
monsieur s'élevait à ce juste une
question
votre parti a souvent pris la défense
des harkis oui ce sont les kurdes
aujourd'hui ce sont des gens qui se sont
battus pour l'occident ce sont des gens
qui écoutaient massacrés dans la guerre
d'irak et la série ce sont des gens qui
sont allés aux pros feront à notre place
pendant que vous étiez tranquillement
dans le jura et vous leur dites comme on
a dit aux harkis il ya plutôt eu il ya
plus de 50 ans reste et je me permettrai
vous les allées ils sont tous les
attraits hors plateau vous me connaissez
pas je me permets bien je vous l'a dit
monsieur vous expliquer ce que je
voulais je pense que la chaux coach des
maquillages la séquence du maquillage
vallauris que d'être intéressant tout ça
qu'on va jusqu'à avancer il reste un peu
mon ire et ce pendant six minutes
une démission j'aimerais bien qu'on
termine en faisant un tour de table on a
vu des mesures concrètes de temps en
temps on a entendu parler d' emmanuel
macron pourquoi est-ce que emmanuel
macron relance ce débat maintenant on va
commencer avec vous monsieur sylvestre
d'après-vous mesure électoraliste
vous avez développé votre idylle
uniquement une mesure électoraliste
c'est à dire au jour d'aujourd'hui il
monsieur macro on se rend bien compte
que une partie de son discours sur la
sur les migrations et l'immigration lui
attirera peut-être des électeurs
supplémentaires pour les projets qui
vient qui vient chasser sur vos terres
en fait c'est une habitude chez lui de
chasser sur les terres un petit peu tout
le monde
au jour d'aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui se
revendique macron on sait pas trop d'où
il est originaire l'eau à dire qui peut
être de droite de gauche anthony poulin
votre vos responsables politiques
nationaux d'europe écologie les verts
ont dit que non seulement emmanuel
macron chasser sur les terres du
rassemblement national mais qui s'était
même dans la perspective des élections
présidentielles de 2022
ce qui suppose qu'au deuxième tour il va
se retrouver face comme la dernière fois
à marine le pen
emmanuel macron essayer de mettre un
clivage il y à l'extrême droite d'un
côté et lui lui de l'autre et un moment
donné il faut il faut comme je vous le
disais convoqué un certain nombre de
figures dans le débat c'est c'est
presque marketing et c'est dommage on
dit de dire cela mais c'est presque
marketing un moment donné de convoquer
la figure du du migrant comme le bouc
émissaire de toutes de tous les maux de
la société pour éviter de parler de
vrais sujets sujets qui préoccupent les
français par exemple justement corps
vous parler des sujets qui préoccupent
les français 66% des français estiment
que justement les étrangers sur notre
sol ne font pas assez d'efforts pour
s'intégrer mais moi je je je renvoie
cette responsabilité à tout le monde y
compris au gouvernement comment on peut
poser le débat de l'immigration et de
l'intégration des personnes migrantes
dans notre pays lorsque dans dans
l'ensemble de nos nos villes on a baissé
les coûts les dotations pour l'aide aux
associations qui faisait cet accueil
on a baissé les contrats aidés et
comment on peut réfléchir ça lorsque le
gouvernement a refusé par exemple le
plan borloo alors jan budar vaut aussi
comme le rassemblement national vous
dites manoeuvres électoralistes
sur la question de l'immigration ce
qu'il fait depuis le début du mandat de
la communication il fait de la
communication à peu de frais on organise
un débat au parlement et je suis très
favorable à tous les débats au parlement
évidemment mais si on considère c'est un
problème majeur ce n'est pas un débat
sans vote qui va résoudre la
problématique on avait voulu il faut
expliquer que donc il ya eu débat à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat mais
que ce n'était pas suivie de vote
donc c'était presque un débat pour rien
c'est ça n'est pas pour rien c'est
sainte débattre ni à une loi sur l'asile
et l'immigration qui a eu lieu il ya un
an qui n'a rien apporté quand même et
tout à l'heure la 17e
il ya d'ailleurs plutôt assoupli les
règles du rock du regroupement familial
et on dit aujourd'hui un problème on va
en discuter mais on va on va rien faire
ça ne sert à rien ça ne sert à rien si
derrière pas des mesures pour autant ses
seins d'en parler et là je contredis
notre collègue d'europe écologie les
verts parce que les c'est toujours ce
thème au rassemblement national ne
jamais en parler ne jamar de mesures
concrètes c'est concrètement justement
renforcer leur ascension n'est pas noir
il fallait pas en parler et nos
dirigeants nationaux n'ont jamais dit
qu'il ne fallait pas en parler il faut
en parler mais il faut en parler
la bonne manière et en parler de la
bonne manière c'est comment on se
mobilise tous pour faire que
l'intégration se passe bien et que
l'accueil soit digne voilà on peut
parler comme ça d'une manière d'en
parler on est d'accord sur les jeux
d'amérique où ils m'ont retiré a priori
une partie du débat et je crois que en
la matière une partie du débat a été
retiré a priori par le président en
opposant certains français aux autres et
c'est sa tactique
je pense que c'est dommage pour
l'ensemble de notre pays et pour
l'ensemble du continent européen
je voulais finir cette émission avec
vous bruno kern vous êtes un ancien
membre du parti socialiste
laurent bouvet qui est un politologue
dit l'aveuglément sur l'immigration est
l'une des raisons de l'échec historique
de la gauche
vous partagez je partage totalement
parce que donc un moment donné à gauche
on a été plus du côté des vertes voyes
l'avenir du petit coeur que de la raison
j'allais dire que mon voisin de droite a
fait un ensemble de griller à droite
juste et bien sûr aujourd'hui il a été
clair dans le débat les plus à droite
que moi je sais pas ce que c'est être à
gauche à droite il ya des gens qui
s'aiment non non c'est pas vous qui
décidez qui est à gauche ou à droite
en fonction de ce que vous pensez je dis
simplement que précisément parce que
nous n'avons pas voulu regarder un
certain nombre de problèmes et de
question que nous posaient les français
je pars de nous en tant qu'ancien élus
et responsables socialistes
nous avons laissé à des gens comme ce
monsieur le monopole d'un débat
l'immigration et jeu et je ne voudrais
pas qu'on retombe dans ce dans cette
espèce de de cul mais nice qui consiste
à dire on accueille tout le monde y
compris les familles et cetera sans
distinction sans rien si on veut
aujourd'hui que les personnes qui
viennent en france soient accueillis
dignement et un avenir puisse travailler
puissent faire venir leurs familles
parce qu'elles y ont droit
emma et moi je suis d'une de je suis
aimé par exemple on voit qu'il ya qui a
convergence avec la avec les
républicains a rejeté à nouveau à hoerdt
pas vous en toc socialisme précisément
non parce que sur le constat jeu
précisément non pas si je risque le
constat du français à l'anglais
mes chances de nationalistes exemple la
gauche à se mobiliser - excusez la
ministre de la justice madame taubira
démissionné et un certain nombre avec
elles n'étaient pas d'accord sur ça donc
ne ne fait pas d' amalgame en permanence
en pour essayer pour essayer de vous
positionner comme un homme au grand
coeur
je voudrais dire simplement une honte ce
mais on a tous un grand coeur autour je
vais au tour de cette app vous vous
occupez en 10 secondes bruno cad si vous
savez conclure au 10 godin sur le débat
or vote sur un projet de loi ou permet
aux idées de s'épanouir et d'être
totalement exprimé quand vous le faites
à partir d'un projet de loi avec des
mesures précises spécifique s'éclate et
c'est là que les positions se
radicalisent et que des propositions
comme celles qui avaient été faites ne
sont pas retenus voilà c'est terminé
c'est voilà donc on a bien compris que
ce débat était g à ses clients comme on
dit entre les uns et les autres
merci messieurs merci de votre attention
et bon dimanche après midi à tous au
revoir
je